pues vamos a darle la bienvenida a
nuestro invitado las conversaciones con
el señor philippe bolan analista
político internacional y representante
del partido de la república en marcha en
bogotá bienvenido y por favor rosa
comience usted con las preguntas buenos
dias philip le quería empezar
preguntando cuáles son las principales
razones por las que la izquierda llega
tan dividida a esta elección buenos días
rosa como viste puse una camisa rosa
pero pálida entonces no olvidemos que la
mayoría del grupo de macrón de gama
venimos de la izquierda es decir que no
podemos decir que la izquierda ha
desaparecido lo que podemos ver es el
partido socialista y los partidos
tradicionales porque también los
partidos republicanos que no van a
llegar a la segunda vuelta que eso sería
la primera vez entonces en este momento
vemos que hay un problema grave de
democracia en todo el mundo vivimos con
la dirección de donald trump en eeuu en
francia y si a un sondeo hace unos días
donde mostraron que 47% de los franceses
no saben cuál es los programas de los
candidatos entonces la gente están
buscando justamente más bien el que
habla bien por ellos
perdió justamente porque su debate fue
catastrófico y la izquierda la gente no
lo entiende a tal punto que a los
comunistas como usted me está diciendo
votan por mi imagen yo soy un tipo
simpático no mostrar programa están
mostrando más quién son ellos vemos que
la campaña que hizo a ni algo fue
catastrófica entonces no supo tener el
carisma porque lo que necesita en este
momento no es una persona capaz de hacer
el trabajo es alguien carismático eso es
grave y ya entonces vemos que también
hay división entonces el partido de
menos yo está creciendo bastante mente y
está chupando la rueda y le están
tomando bastantes votos a los partidos
tradicionales muchos pensaba hace unos
años que los verdes socialistas ponían
justamente alcanzar este momento vemos
que está en sexta posición entonces lo
que la sorpresa de estas elecciones fue
más bien lo que dijiste anteriormente
rosa de la subida y esta extrema derecha
populista que está creciendo entonces ya
sabemos pero la entrada se estimó que es
que tomó bastantes votos populares es
decir que él empezó a tomar votos de la
izquierda tradicionales comunistas u
otros y entonces hay una dispara la
gente no entiende el mensaje socialista
desde que justamente muchos pasamos a
mccall es decir que era justamente un
poquito el 'voto útil' alguien que es
capaz de hacer el trabajo a alguien que
nos podía representar y conocían a los
doce pues el señor bola quería seguir
hablando con usted precisamente de esta
iniciativa del voto útil que promueve en
esta campaña
el grupo de mediación con la esperanza
de cerrar esa brecha de unos cinco
puntos con marie le pen y poder pasar a
la segunda vuelta usted qué opina de
esta estrategia de voto ahora a mí me
tocó el voto útil cuando teníamos que
votar por chirac o por lope entonces
muchos pasamos justamente apoyando el
crack porque no podíamos dejar el frente
nacional jean-marie le pen al poder el
voto útil no es fácil en la primera
vuelta es decir que menos yo batea
dificultad a pesar que menos yo es un
candidato un poquito específico porque
él logra justamente subir las últimas
semanas entonces vamos a ver los
próximos sondeos pero menos son él sabe
justamente terminar de maratoniano y
precisamente hablando de menos son una
de sus propuestas faros también era uno
de los principales reclamos de los
chalecos amarillos era la constitución
de una sexta república nos podría
explicar qué pondría este cambio si lo
que quiere es una reforma total del
sistema diciendo que esto no está
funcionando es decir que está fomentando
justamente una desconfianza de los
franceses en el sistema de la quinta
república eso para mí es peligroso
porque vimos que esta función bien o mal
estaba funcionando entonces cambiar las
reglas del juego bueno lo visual jon
aval de gol pero ahora necesario
entonces con la quinta república en este
momento lo que quiere hacer es
obviamente darle más poder a los
ciudadanos lo que todo el mundo estamos
buscando lo vimos ayer justamente el
debate de los seis candidatos
interesante porque tomaron una muestra
de 200 franceses que hacían sus
preguntas antes eran solamente los
periodistas ahora queremos más que la
social civil el francés común entra en
las discusiones los debates pero yo
estoy de acuerdo que entra pero si vemos
que 47% no saben de qué hablan los
candidatos es un peligro también bueno y
entretanto en balance yo no ha sido
partidario entre otras cosas de dejar la
unión europea y la otan en un discurso
bastante fuerte aunque el candidato se
ha esforzado por ser más moderado y eso
se ha visto en las encuestas le alcanza
porque con una guerra cercana en ucrania
por el contrario ésta ha sido la ocasión
defender el europeísmo y una respuesta
en conjunto en bloque que ha beneficiado
al presidente candidato de manuel macro
a esta guerra horrible que hay en este
momento obviamente da una conciencia de
los europeos de unirse entonces para
tener soberanía que sea soberanía al
nivel de energía sobre la unidad de
valdés defensas al nivel al alimentaria
entonces ella se está mostrando
justamente a qué puede servir o ropa
para afrontar justamente un tema así tan
horroroso que lo que está buscando
entonces muchos franceses por eso quema
con su vio en las últimas encuestas
porque la gente se dieron cuenta que
europa es una necesidad tenemos que
hacerla y hacerla bien es decir que esta
filosofía que nació en los 50
justamente en estrasburgo hay que
continuarla eso es básico la lo de la
otan es otro debate que pueden
concentrar es decir que lo vimos con el
tema mcinnis la dependencia de eeuu que
a sarkozy nos volvió a poder ahí
entonces es por eso que sarkozy también
nos va a ayudar a abrir picas entonces
eso es discutible porque no olvidemos
que el general de gaulle sacó a patadas
la otan de francia y ahora estamos
pensando va a haber en toulouse la sede
tratando del espacio o sea que hay una
dependencia fuerte en este y ya esté
estamos creando una europa común a pesar
de esto los alemanes van a comprar
aviones de eeuu entonces hay un hay un
debate al nivel de estados y dos también
más que el debate de europa creo que el
debate de europa ahora la mayoría los
franceses saben que sirve justamente
esta cosa y que esto puede justamente
tener material vimos que el presiente
editar ya llamó a comprar petróleo de
madera al coritiba entre los diferentes
países entonces empezar a pensar más en
común y disculpe durante este mandato ha
habido mucho descontento en las calles
sede contra el gobierno de macrón no los
chalecos amarillos como comentábamos
pero también contra la reforma de las
pensiones movimientos estudiantiles de
los conductores de la densidad etcétera
y cree que la izquierda ha logrado
capitalizar este descontento porque
muchas de los reclamos en las calles
figuran en una del programa de medición
precisa figura del programa de menos son
pero cuando hicieron encuestas vieron
que la mayor cosa mayor se fueron a
votar por los extremos derecha es decir
que se llama jean-loup en óseas de mujer
el tema del poder adquisitivo que es
busquets o decimos tiene dos orillas de
acción
adquisitivo y el otro que es
en francia entonces asustando la gente y
a lo que vemos es que no supieron
justamente a entender lo que está
pasando es decir que el problema es el
ya cubismo y estamos muy centralizado en
parís entonces los políticos parecidos
tienen dificultad de entender lo que
viene detrás del periférico y eso creo
que es el problema de no entendieron
bien la gente que viven un poquito a las
afueras que venimos a hacer una
población de cargos dependientes
entonces eso ha cambiado el tema de los
estudiantes vimos que fue todo el mundo
es decir que no solamente francia y
decir que estar en forma escolar que
porque es uno de los temas fuertes de
macon hay dos aquí el tema de la reforma
escolar lo vimos con los kinder y los
primeros años de primaria donde
dividieron las clases para poder
ocuparse mejor de los niños y en la
reforma de la salud a la reforma de las
jubilaciones eso sí está en el tema que
hay que hace una reforma rápida porque
justamente la tasa de natalidad es
trabajando muy bien usted comenzó esta
entrevista hablándonos acerca del
socialismo y las peripecias que ha
tenido que sobrepasar el año pasado
el aniversario número 40 de la llegada
del primer presidente socialista de la
quinta república françois mitterrand una
izquierda que en el pasado llegó sin
problemas la segunda vuelta pero que
cayó a pique especialmente después de la
presidencia de françois hollande se han
llegado a llamar este quinquenio como el
suicidio de la izquierda francesa por
algunos medios internacionales porque en
su opinión no ha podido recuperarse a la
izquierda y bueno se le ve con
dificultad luchando para llegar este año
a segunda bueno aquí hablando de escala
específicamente el partido socialista
entonces yo recuerdo que estuvo en uno
del último gran del congreso en un papel
de la salle en parís donde estaban todos
los líderes socialistas de europa europa
era socialista durante una diseña y él
como comentaba lo de los de mitterrand
es decir que lo de mitigar su política
después neoliberal descontento a muchos
justamente de la izquierda entonces se
fueron a más extremos después vemos que
justamente el tema del carlismo y el
tema importante es que perdieron y con
la pandemia peor peor perdieron todo el
puerta a puerta estar con la gente
hablando con la gente que lo que está
haciendo si miramos en este momento
manifestaciones quien ganase
lastimosamente el es capaz de llevar
miles de personas a sus eventos los
socialistas no tienen esta cosa este
carisma de llevar la gente a pesar de
menos son obviamente que es un fenómeno
aparte pero primero es también opción
que es un fenómeno que logró justamente
captar gran parte y lo vemos en este
momento que a tercer o cuarto en los
sondeos vemos desde otro lado o el
partido socialista tradicional que se
perdió se perdió totalmente y el
abandono
cómo se llama nuestra ex primer ministro
como se llama ya no recuerdo el nombre
que la frase es que se había presentado
y después renunció al partido cuando
perdieron las elecciones justamente
cuando él no llegó a la segunda vuelta
la cara que hizo la decepción eso
decepción a muchos entonces cuando llegó
más con muchos de los socialistas
pasamos a apoyarlo recordamos que el
alcalde libio que era uno de los pilares
socialistas fue el primero a apoyarlo lo
vemos ahora en esta campaña muchos
alcaldes muchos senadores pasaron del
grupo apoyando a maco porque nos parece
una política social razón y obviamente
con neoliberalismo fuerte pero en este
momento de lo que está pasando a nivel
de la globalización necesitamos un
presidente así
pero precisamente macrón llegó al poder
por la caída de fillón del líder de los
republicanos precisamente en las
elecciones no de 2017 a raíz de ese
escándalo por haber dado trabajo a su
mujer etcétera y ahí fue cuando macrón
despegó en las 50 en las encuestas y se
le atribuyó a precisamente haber
recuperado gran parte del electorado de
derecha usted considera que hay gente de
izquierdas que está votando a makro y
por supuesto es decir que obviamente y
gran parte de los republicanos pasaron
los moderados por ejemplo los radicales
pasaron del lado de mallo pero también
gran parte los socialistas podemos decir
que más o menos el 30 por ciento fácil
de la base y la base que nos sigue es
una base socialista al inicio entonces
gente que viene de partido tradicional
socialista y el partido socialismo de
socialista en particular mire en las
primarias de izquierda fueron un fracaso
su principal promotora ni siquiera llegó
a la candidatura qué pasa con los otros
candidatos de izquierda porque están tan
lejos entre sí entre todos nos llegan a
sumar más del 30 por ciento de los
apoyos y vemos ejemplos como el de una
vanidad que rechaza por ejemplo que se
apoyó a mención en este llamado 'voto
útil' pese a que por ejemplo su propia
candidatura ya está hundida y pues no
hablemos tampoco de pequeñas portero
pero hundida pero bueno hay dos casos
aquí pk es está grave pero la ventaja y
va a tener a un reembolso de su campaña
pero hablando del partido el partido
socialista si llega a no llegar a un 5
por ciento no bate de reembolso
recordamos que hace unos años tuvieron
que vender sucede porque no tenía
suficiente dinero para mantener
repartido entonces cómo se financia a
los partidos políticos están bien los
resultados a las elecciones pero aquí
podemos decir que hay dos selecciones
hay la primera acción es que estamos
hablando que es la presidencial y la
otra que se está preparando que son la
diputación que va a ser importante aquí
vemos que justamente ya se perdieron ya
se es va a ser una catástrofe es decir
de tener 3 % es algo inesperado lo vimos
cuando hubo la caída del partido
comunista en francia que siempre tenía
entre 10 y 12 por ciento y con mi
trabajo y empezó a estar debajo de los 5
por ciento todos los problemas que hubo
dentro del partido y aquí vamos a ver lo
mismo es decir que este partido va a
explotar con la presidencia tenemos qué
qué va a hacer con la diputación y la
diputación llegan nuevos actores
por ejemplo la derecha va a llegar el
partido o viso que no tenemos que
olvidar de la express del ex primer
ministro francés y ahí pues que tener
justamente una sorpresa yo creo que
edward philip se está preparando también
del otro lado la caída de pecas le puede
servir bastante entonces al nivel de
derecha yo creo que va a ver una
reconstrucción a través de un partido lo
mismo que está muy cercano a la macro
entonces hay una red de reestructuración
pero yo veo complicado y además usted
habló no hay que olvidar que ellos
tenían bases universitaria yo entré del
partido socialista porque yo estaba del
lunes y de un sindicato estudiantil en
la época y estaba con él manuel valls
lado mío trabajando y eso se perdió es
decir que los sindicatos estudiantiles
en este momento se han perdido
totalmente han perdido las bases de las
universidades lo vimos con las
manifestación que hay en contra el
gobierno pero que siempre hay pero en
contra justamente de los partidos
tradicionales y aquí está creciendo en
muchas universidades justamente gente
del epp en gente de menos de gente desde
muy y eso es un peligro es decir qué
realidad que había antes ya lo está
desapareciendo y sin embargo macrón va
liderando y el partido socialista
teníamos un periódico que usted mostró
que era la liberación y liberación y a
cambio de mago entonces era un poquito
nuestro órgano oficial de comunicación y
precisamente entonces en relación a lo
que decía como cree que ha afectado la
izquierda que la derecha o la extrema
derecha e incluso macrón con sus
políticas como la ley del separatismo
estén imponiendo en el debate público
pues eso temas que son propios de la
derecha como la inmigración el islam la
integración hoy en el caso desde moore
el gran reemplazo no la gran sustitución
y a esta teoría racista abiertamente
porque creo que los franceses en este
momento aquí voy a ser duro les falta
cultura política es más fácil hablar de
esos temas quiere hablar cómo voy a
mejorar la relación internacional lo voy
a mejorar la reforma de salud diciendo
el enemigo está aquí es esta persona es
el extranjero es el musulmán eso es
fácil la gente no está así entonces si
cambiamos esto está bien es decir que si
miramos el programa desde nubes un
chiste realmente es un chiste y es
solamente basándose en eso diciendo yo
tengo la solución y las soluciones que
vamos a echar los extranjeros entonces
en este momento la gente no quieren
pensar no quiere reflexionar y no
entiende a qué sirve los politiqueros
cómo afecta a la izquierda precisamente
esta imposición porque me la misión por
ejemplo habla de la crío lización no de
la de la sociedad pero una posible
respuesta no a este discurso somos un
país creador somos un país creador de
todas buenas no hay que olvidar que
nosotros podemos invadidos por los
francos y es por eso que se llama
francia entonces los galos ya no ya no
hay está está lo que pasa es que los
discursos socialistas yo creo que son
demasiado difícil para entender por la
gente ese es el problema es la
dificultad de entender qué es el
socialismo lo vemos en américa latina de
decir que el socialismo como lo
estigmatizan para ellos es no le vamos a
sacar sus sierras y le vamos a sacar a
esto sino a la larga de forma un poquito
con cambio en los años 80 con la llegada
de thatcher y la habilidad de regantes
entonces empezando a en burgués ser a la
clase media hora clase baja más bien
donde hablo en casas y todo eso y toda
la gente tiene miedo de perder lo que
tiene entonces él no quieren reformar se
ha se han vuelto conservadores en este
caso entonces piensa que la derecha les
va a defender sus intereses en muchos
países justamente la derecha no está al
favor de de cómo se llama de la clase
media y la clase popular con la
mundialización entonces mandar a
empresas en otros países y todo eso
entonces es complicado entender cómo
está funcionando la política en este
momento y el problema es que también hay
falso socialismo aquí por ejemplo el
país vecino de venezuela que no es un
socialismo lo que vemos es que uno se
pone unas etiquetas y entonces se
estigmatiza y piensa que es así y la
derecha piensa que la derecha les va a
permitir a un poder adquisitivo más alto
entonces porque son cosas simplista
simplifican las cosas y eso es el
problema
mire es que uno de los ejemplos de esta
dificultad que tiene ahora el socialismo
y la izquierda en general en francia en
estas elecciones para acercarse al
electorado es por ejemplo el discurso
ecologista o el llamado discurso socio
ecologista digamos que a melanson le ha
ido un poco mejor que a los demás
candidatos de izquierda en este tema
pero por qué les cuesta porque no cala
el problema de la ecología primero es
para conquistar los jóvenes entonces es
una prioridad - son la ventaja es que es
un viejo candidato conoce -12 conoce
bien justamente las carpetas sabe que y
lo vemos su manera de presentarse
justamente haciendo todo un solo
anteriormente con hologramas esta vez
con luces y sonidos y olores entonces
hay un conocimiento más sé cómo se llama
puntual sobre el tema además por los
ecologistas están graves en este momento
con el tema de la energía porque vemos a
la escasa estos es el tema de regresar
al carbón no creo que sea la mejor idea
lo que vemos es que la ahora todos los
partidos tiene hasta marín repente de un
componente ecologista es decir que todos
los depender todos los partidos han
tomado esta cápsula ecologista lo que es
bueno el partido socialista fue el
primero hacerlo justamente con unos
candidatos de iu con alianzas con los
ecologistas ahí y ahora lo han integrado
es decir la la ecología sabemos que
ahora es transversal a todos los
partidos todos los partidos la montes
acaba de salir el informe justamente
catastrófico mostrando el estado del
planeta y que salió en francia
últimamente vemos que ya la gente están
pero lo que vemos es la preocupación
principal en este momento es el poder
adquisitivo entonces la gente los
jóvenes que no van a votar mucho están
más enfocados en la parte ecológica pero
los que votan va a ser las personas
mayores lo que están cerca de la
jubilación y esos de la jubilación
tienen miedo a la reforma de macrón
claro precisamente en relación a lo que
comenta que quizás los jóvenes no votan
mucho y también a lo que decía al
principio de la entrevista de esta
división entre lo rural y lo urbano cómo
afecta precisamente este desinterés o
esta abstención particularmente a la
izquierda a todos y yo creo que
los extremos con sus mensajes de odio
saben movilizar entonces yo creo que eso
va a haber lugar movilizar los los
jóvenes el día de primer día y recuerdo
para las últimas lex elecciones
legislativas en francia fue interesante
entrevistar a los jóvenes en la calle
edición 20 a votar si si voy a votar
pero usted sabe que falla
y así la noche hicieron adecuado en el
canal creo que es falso entonces existía
la adicción a esta entrevista a los
jóvenes sabiendo su intención de voto al
día después para saber entonces si yo
voy a votar por esto no pero fue ya no
olvide y estar cuál es decir que eso es
grave eso es clave es decir que ahora
montar una aplicación street in there en
francia interesante para saber qué
candidatos vamos a apuntar tratando de
recordarles que hay que votar es decir
el joven moderado que sea
república los republicanos que veo
todavía parte modera o va con
socialistas entonces yo creo que va a
ser difícil para que vaya a votar pero
sabemos que las fuerzas de menor son las
de repente si está movilizada si las
decimos que estamos visas y lo vimos
porque van a manifestación y todo eso
entonces son gente que van a salir a la
calle que llueve o que haga calor para
ir a votar y eso es el problema es decir
que solamente una franja de la población
y no votan por ideología votan por
justamente un eslogan votan por hacer
parte de una manada y eso sí es la parte
más asustado muy complicado y bueno ya
para llegar al cierre de esta entrevista
uno de los mensajes que más ha calado en
esta campaña presidencial en francia
pues es precisamente el de la guerra en
ucrania mientras que manuel macrón de
fin del europeísmo hay mensajes más
ambiguos por parte de por ejemplo de
mala acción de pepe desde la misma marín
de pena hacia la retórica que debe
adoptarse con vladimir putin usted qué
opina de la postura primordialmente del
ancho
y yo creo que eso es pura farándula es
decir que si vemos lo que quiere putin
ya sabemos él quiere tomar el donbass
quiere con tomar justamente odessa y
después irse es decir tenerlos
totalmente amarrados controlados y tener
esos puertos la idea es que quiere
obviamente que sea salgan que la otan no
venga acerca de su casa el discurso de
múnich de 2007 los dos lo demostró es
decir que en este momento creo que la
gente no entiende que quiere mostrarse
un poquito como el perito que está
gritando es decir que es complicado
putin ya sabemos que tiene ya está
haciendo sus cosas horribles y va a
continuar el problema es que puede haber
retórica puede haber cosas que pueda ser
vemos alemania están amarrado con el
tema del gas es decir cambiar el
proveedor de petróleo es fácil cambiar
el petróleo y gas- alemania dijo dos
años entonces va a tener que negociar lo
que va a pasar después que se va a
terminar esta guerra todo el mundo va a
aplaudir a rusia porque necesitamos lo
necesitamos en materias primas entonces
en este momento él está desconociendo la
política internacional rusia es un actor
que lastimosamente vamos a necesitar
esos próximos años no no lo podemos
dejar así y vemos que a tal punto que
mandaron
de esta opción es a negociar entre la
vida como para explicar que irán iba a
entrar justamente como aliado para el
tema de petróleo que es una cosa que la
absurda hace unos veces entonces la
política internacional al menos yo no se
encarga es decir que el único obviamente
porque es sus cargos y es responsable de
europa en este momento que es bajo es el
único que tiene que tener esta batuta y
no puede decir cualquier cosa que
nosotros si están diciendo pero saben
que no lo puede hacer bueno pues el
señor mola muchísimas gracias a usted
por estar con nosotros